asking medical students what they wish
they knew before they started med school
hey
what's something you wish you knew
you're gonna be poor for many many years
before you get rich hey Clara oh hi
what's something you wish you knew I
wish someone had told me to try and make
friends satire medicine because even
though it's nice to be with medic
friends when you're in a medical it can
be a lot of investment surgery hey lovey
hi what's something you wish you knew
probably there's no need to buy any
books I just use online resources like
past Med and they're great
rosilla what's something you wish you
knew I wish I knew not to stress too
much about getting into med school and
how I got in because once again
hey Cat hi what's something you wish you
knew that somebody told me how much
medical school would affect my mental
health
hey Emmy hi what's something you wish
you knew um probably wish that I knew
that the medical school would just send
us out to the middle of nowhere for our
placements